mais d'abord contre le coc vite 19 la
touraine en bonne place dans l'effort de
guerre après récit pharma mon et fareva
à amboise le site delpharm à
chambray-lès-tours va lui aussi
participer à la production de vaccins
annonces du président de la république
qui promettent une aide supplémentaire
de 20 millions d'euros
paul boyer a pu rencontrer la directrice
du site le site delpharm emploie 270
salariés en cdi dans le bâtiment bleu et
blanc qui se trouve juste derrière moi
leur mission principale fabriquer des
seringues préremplies qui permettront
d'injecter le vaccin plus facilement
il ne fabrique pas la substance active
mais interviennent après la production
soit celle de remplissage et de
conditionnement des doses c'est à but de
pouvoir faire des vaccins le plus
rapidement possible et on était des
effectivement part cela par l'état c'est
ce qui a été annoncé par le président ce
matin à hauteur de 20 millions d'euros
donc il va nous permettre de vraiment
accélérer le projet et lui donner un
délai beaucoup plus court que ce qu'on
fait habituellement pour ce type
d'ateliers sur le site delpharm de
chambray-lès-tours une partie sera
spécialement dédiée à la fabrication des
seringues pré remplies pour ce faire la
directrice générale a accepté de nous
montrer le futur lieu auprès de 50
salariés travailleront d'arrache-pied
pour produire ce vaccin l'arrivée
effectivement des personnes sera
crescendo alors il ya d'abord une partie
de personnes qui vont être là pour la
construction de l'atelier et puis
l'achat et l'installation des
équipements leur qualification et donc
ça va monter en puissance de 10 20 30 et
jusqu'à 40 personnes au pic du projet et
puis après on passera dans la phase de
production ou là effectivement de
manière crescendo on aura prendre
quarante cinquante personnes qui
viendront en fonction de la montée en
puissance de la production le site et
dale farm de chambray-lès-tours est le
sixième site en france à produire le
vaccin freizer biotech